going to be talking about simping okay
and so as we get started I'm going to
ask a question to everybody
do you guys know what a simp actually is
I've been one
okay go for it yeah I've been one female
simple okay go for it we got my thing so
basically
in my experience as a simp that does way
too much for someone that would never do
the same for them
but I love him though so your citizen
what is what is two what is too much
like what did you essentially anything
when you're simp you essentially
shouldn't be doing anything for that
person
so anything you do is too much but you
do as much as to think people might say
what is that your man
no but I love him no I was just
wondering like what is too much like
what were you doing okay in my example
okay he had a girlfriend but
you had a guy who already had a
girlfriend yeah but so what are you
doing with him
maybe a side chick on it yeah so
basically you're a side chick okay so
okay I didn't know he had a girlfriend
yeah but when you found out he had a
girlfriend you stayed with him right
yeah because that's my baby so you got
side chick energy
not in general because I don't want
people
don't have a girl however him especially
because I didn't find out he had a goal
for about what was it like two three
weeks
I'm the type of person that I go with
energy so if I meet you in person and
it's good energy I will link you every
day so it's like you know like when
you're in love island or Big Brother
house two weeks is like two months so
essentially them two weeks was my two
months she's saying she loves a thrill I
love the fruit so in my head I was like
yeah this is my money and your men after
two weeks how long has it been now how
long like how long until you cut it off
oh no no no that's that's are you still
with him
I mean it sounds like you he said she
still loves him so so
it's going on here when did I meet him
so you're saying let me just yeah it's
been about a year and a half one more
time wait wait hold on hold on a year a
year so okay so let me just so after two
three weeks you found out he has a
girlfriend yeah and instead of saying
you know what I'm gonna cut my losses
and get out no no you were like let me
just ride this till I die so she was not
listening to the advice
does the girlfriend know oh hell no no
no no no no no so the girlfriend has no
idea bro
by the way about it you're a scientist I
personally feel like she probably knows
but she don't know it's me so it's fine
is
anybody else been a Sim
I I I've heard that I think it's like
okay so it's Sim right it's someone who
caters to anything and everything a
woman wants and actually showers her
with love and attention and doesn't
necessarily get it back
giving their attention that's a you
shower her with everything and you love
her and you want her and you show all
this kind of stuff but she's kind of
like yeah so you're kind of simp without
okay so you've never you tell him you've
never been a simp for a woman I've never
been a Sim but uh I can uh I can tell
that I've been always
someone who's who's really caring and
someone who's as a man right if I think
if you if you if you were raised in the
right household and you see your parents
or your father
taking care of their wives
and uh they raise you to be
they raise you to grow up to become a
gentleman
I think there's okay let's just like
okay I'm gonna step back and explain to
you okay let's just say at school yeah
you have this this kid a very smart kid
you know
but people don't call Smart Kids smart
kids they call them weirdos or like
something else different names because
they're smart right right so uh what I
don't understand is whatever man is just
a gentleman but end up like end up
quoting a Sim
have you ever as a man felt like you
were given more to a woman we always
said than she was given to you we we as
a man to this day we always give more
than modern women give that's how I feel
okay you know because as a man as a
provider you know I think but you're
married though aren't you I am married
and uh and the reason why I say that is
because women expect more
from us than we do expect from them
[Music]
you know women expect more from from men
to do than we as a man expect women to
to give us right so uh either way
whether you're a simple gentleman or a
gangster
whatever you call yourself you still as
a man
give you more
okay so why is it so why is the Sim so
narrowed down to the gender though when
it comes to men that is my big question
because
I don't know many female simps to be
fair like I know I had no money
the girls that like usually say they're
Sims it's like all they offer is [ __ ]
thank you all right
no 90 of girls it's like what else do
you bring to you know why ninety percent
no no no no do you know why because
goals are socially accepted to be Sims
because you're a girl so when a girl
does too much
so right so say if a guy likes me and
he's going over the top I'm airing him
he's still messaging me I don't give him
attention he's buying me stuff you're
now a simp it's embarrassing right now
say if a guy don't text me back I still
message him like I don't know much about
I'm still doing stuff for him you're a
girl so it's a bit more now in society
people are gonna judge a girl less for
being a Sim than a boy no but uh
I understand what she means though I
understand what she is expect no it's
true because to kind of Chase off the
boys well boys are not expected to chase
okay but but as a woman what would you
prefer would you prefer I want guys to
chasing me okay so hang on okay that's a
very interesting um thing so if you want
guys to a certain extent right this is
where I'm gonna go so if you want a guy
to chase you yeah if a guy's constantly
chasing you and showing that he's always
because the guy I used to talk to I
would probably see him two three times a
week and he'd probably ring me every day
but when I ring him he don't ring back
but you like that though
but if he Rings me let me know but you
like that though right like like what
like but like but like but like but you
like that but like if he rings ring me
and I don't call back there's an issue
no but the thing is women like that
Chase they like guys like the chase no
no but hang on if a guy is chasing you
down too much hit this no exactly yeah
too much time yeah it is it depends it
depends how I'm responding if I'm
actively responding to you in a way that
suggests you can still chat to me
cool if I'm airing out your thing stop
what you're doing immediately stop what
you're doing if I air you it's not if I
air you two one too many times it's a
actually just stop chatting guys why
don't you just say you're not interested
guys this is why because
let me just say to the camera this is
why nice guys finish last no let me
laugh explain into you why okay you
cannot do that let me explain why
aggression let me explain why right you
say why don't you just cut off the guy
that's chasing you but you don't really
want the attention because I promise you
the guy that I want is not giving me
enough attention that I don't need yours
your attention is feeding my ego however
when my man replies yeah go away okay so
so let me just so you're gonna use the
other guys for attention listen and then
chase after the guy you don't like
because how would you feel if you were
in their shoes because I'm a hypocrite
because you started you started you
started the podcast saying that men
ain't [ __ ] but you kind of are being
ain't [ __ ] to men yep I'm a hypocrite do
you know what it is
I feel like if I'm intentionally airing
your message or not responding to you
you know what it is if a guy is airing
my messages and I choose to double
triple message him I know what it is and
I'm choosing to be that person if you're
messaging me and I air you you message
me again I a you message me again and I
a you but I enjoy the attention you do
give me when your messaging me picking
me up but I'm choosing to a you you know
what it is this is why this is why you
know what it is I go this is why I tell
men just focus on yourself
guys [ __ ] yourself because you will
never ever ever be able to understand
the psychology of a woman no because for
as a guy right does that make sense to
us it does does that make sense but
because as a man if we say we want X Y
and Z that means we want X Y and Z right
go for it yeah I mean a woman will say
they want X Y and Z but if you give them
X Y and Z they're like no I don't know
if I want that it's like but you said
you wanted it I can't like that's not me
though personally if you give me exactly
what I want your mama now
[Music]
he chases me and I let him stay there no
hang on you're actually with a man
that's not your man you're a side chick
you just said earlier you're a side
chick no not anymore but you were a side
chick you used to be a savior you know
why though you know what I didn't go in
saying I want to be next if I knew from
the beginning I'd rather I'd rather be
no no I'd rather be I mean I'd rather be
single yeah then than knowing that I'm a
friend let me learn with benefit yeah
right oh oh I'm buying this girl who has
the who has a boyfriend already I wonder
let me laugh the man no the man we don't
do that like we don't we don't Batman we
don't mind girls that has boyfriend
already let me know but for women it's
fine for them let me speak let me speak
no no finish finish bro but for
for for girls it's fine for them to know
them well in the head that this guy that
they're sleeping with are not their man
right but you don't do that listen if as
men we know if our if a woman that we're
sleeping with yeah is getting penis from
somewhere else
I have sex don't get me wrong I feel
like there's always an end goal to end
up with someone but sometimes you know
in the time that someone you're mad
sexually attracted to and they can stay
around until you find whatever you need
to find don't get me wrong if I met the
guy and you had a girlfriend in the jump
I wouldn't have entertained it sounds
like a little bit
I mean come on
I have a serious question though so have
you ever asked him like what his
girlfriend has that you don't
no no no no no I'm just thinking like if
I was gonna if I couldn't take it if I
was gonna be a side chick should I
compete if you're gonna do it anyway if
you're gonna do it anyway do you know
what it is
oh she's good she's good looking right
oh yeah all right so oh my God
let me ask a question if if he he um
broke up with his girlfriend impossible
not with me no I'm sorry if he broke up
with his girlfriend and said I would
just want to be impossible why why is
that impossible because he cheated with
me no but I'm saying no but no but if he
said I'm gonna break up with my
girlfriend and I'm gonna be with you
just you and me possible would you be
with him impossible why is that I'm not
is that I know that's you wouldn't be
with him listen come away
because you said you love this guy so
you would be with him right listen
am I a bit of an idiot for this guy
absolutely however
I'm a chosen idiot as in I choose to be
there you're a chosen idiot I feel like
the main chick is worse than the side
chick do you know why because the side
chick knows she's a side chick she knows
what her world is she knows the main
chick is thinking that's my man oh
that's I love him no we both yeah but
that but the manager gets the commitment
yeah I suppose
yeah but he ain't leaving her for years
and he ain't leaving her for you no
that's fine so either way she is the
chosen one do you know what I mean
there's no chosen one in this situation
everybody's a twin
what you require in a relationship he's
just playing both of you he's telling
that you're my girl he's telling you I
like it
yeah
but she might she never you never know
she might know throughout all of human
history the top guys have had multiple
women they've always had a main chick in
the concubines yeah so so in this
situation no no offense you're the
concubine from what I know of the
situation she be getting DMS from other
girls so she semi knows however I feel
like there's a difference between say if
I'm with a man that's I'm with Drake and
then all of a sudden Drake's not with
you
no let's say I'm officially with Drake
yeah but he's not weird and then all of
a sudden someone richer and more power
comes along am I necessarily going to
leave Drake just because something
better because so I only have money
did you get what I'm saying as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible